ну привід за яким не хотілося би
збиратися на трансляціях
ви бачите що відбувається зараз ми
прощаємося з нашими героями
це Олег Барна і його командир Валерій
щойно відбулося
що не відбулося прощання в
Михайлівському
зараз ті хто
хоче
переміщається на майдан для того щоб
віддати останню шану Героям
я транслюю це для того щоб ви тихо зміг
приїхати не зміг бути сьогодні
з нами могли теж побачити
могли теж побути могли теж віддати шану
Нашим героям так само так само як і я
зараз хода буде рухатися
по майдану Хто не встиг прийти в
Михайлівський
друзі Приходьте Приходьте бо це важливо
Це важливо для родини героя це важливо
для їхніх друзів це важливо для всіх
ми маємо віддати шануємо
А я вам буду показувати все що
відбувається
я попрошу єдине що вас всіх написати чи
Мене добре
чути чи видно нормально чи картинка
добра Чи ви чуєте звук
Я вибачаюся за те що в мене трохи такий
не веселий сьогодні не трохи унили їх
буде стрім бо в мене серце теж болить
разом з усіма
побачити зараз Я сплюся трошки нижче
покажу вам скільки людей дуже багато
насправді
слишне відео видно дергается картинка ну
картинка буде дьоргатися на жаль бо я
йду Ми спустимося зараз на майдан Дякую
друзі Дякую Дякую
Ми спустимося зараз на майдан і вже не
так буде смикатися я вам покажу сьогодні
до речі прийшли
на диво і Ну ясно що колеги по ЄС але й
прийшли слуги народу Я бачила
стефанчука
загинув Степан Господи Боже загинув Олег
Барна Степан його брат тут зараз на
похоронах це наш друг дуже хороший і
командир Олега загинув
в бою
і зараз на жаль ми прощаємося з ними
бачите люди йдуть і люди все перебувають
приходять приєднуються доходи
[музика]
насправді дуже сумно
батьки які цікаві
жовтоблакитні з квіточками я бачила
сьогодні діток маленьких Це я вам хочу
сказати що в нас вже зовсім інша нація
зовсім інша нація
вже дітки з малого-малого Віку знають що
таке Наші герої
На жаль знають що що їх ховають
пане Олеже Дейнега Я вам написала
вірніше сказала це Олег Барна для тих
хто не знає Олега Олег колишній депутат
Верховної Ради
дуже крутий чоловік
який став відомим на весь світ тим що з
парламентською трибуни
послав Путіна нахуй
але не тільки цим багато хто не знав що
він служив в АТО ще давніше після
початку повномасштабного вторгнення Він
знову пішов на фронт
ще вік в нього був вже 56 років але він
сказав що він не може бути осторонь він
пішов на службу і рвався завжди в бій
я його Я знаю що рідні відмовляли
просили не ризикувати але він пішов
в останньому бою на жаль він загинув
тому отак
це я зараз вам показую
Це йде ідуть родини
ідуть оце в формі біля Петра
Олексійовича брат Олега Стьопа Степан
Барна він в десятці 10-й
гірсько-штурмовій бригаді зараз теж
приїхав з фронту
за такого хрінового приводу Вибачте це
дуже важко
тут Стьопа і Олега мама є
тут є Наскільки я знаю Олега дружина
мама
командира Олегова в машині їде
в сусідньому катафалку
ми в неї був єдиною дитиною а тому
це взагалі дуже важка історія
бачите люди по дорозі теж
зустрічають знімають поліція супроводжує
нашу ходу Дякую їм величезне за це
[музика]
я підходила до Степана
ну
питала як вам сказав що
ми своє вже відплакали
Я думаю що за Олега
цим творям прилетить дуже дуже добре
да друзі Я теж плачу Я намагаюся не
плакати в ефірі
але насправді це дуже важко це дуже
важко тому що
Ми їздили вчора
з Петром олексійовичем
поїздку на схід
ну по-перше спілкувалися з хлопцями
що самому по собі Вони класні вони
військові наші вони дуже заряджені
покажу вам зараз поки що як виглядає
наша хода приєднуйтеся Хто не встиг
Приходьте на майдан Ми вже наближаємося
там буде буде кілька годин тривати
церемонія пам’ятна так от ми
спілкувалися з хлопцями вони розказують
звичайно і про втрати і
про Перемоги але ще Найбільше мене
Скажімо так зворушило і вибило трошки з
Колі це
цвинтар під Харковом
і кількість жовто-блакитних прапорів на
ньому
Ну я просто хочу щоб всі розуміли що
слова про те якою є ціна цієї війни це
не просто слова
це не просто слова це конкретна
кількість
жовто-блакитних стягів кожному місці
цієї країни
Sorry вже за таке що воно звучить трохи
як пафосом
але так воно є друзі так воно є
Ми йдемо на майдан я вам покажу
колону поширюйте це відео Я вас дуже
прошу це зробити Перше Ми давно не були
в ефірі
і тому ютубчик трохи нас
приглушив а по-друге
Я хочу щоб якомога більше людей побачили
цю трансляцію побачили наших хлопців бо
на жаль про них не покажуть напевно в
єдиному Марафоні бо вони були Ну Олег
точно був порохоботом Я читаю ваші
коментарі
про Зеленського про те що не було би
війни ви знаєте я не хочу коментувати це
це під час цієї ходи
Я не хочу навіть свою власну думку
про це казати тому що ми сьогодні не про
це
ми сьогодні не про це
Так я зараз я тут піднімуся Почекайте
секунду теж напився
щоб провести їх покажу вам бачите багато
фотографів працює і їм теж величезна
Дякую за те що вони прийшли ми бачили
іноземні ЗМІ це насправді дуже цінно
дуже цінно що вони показують наших
бійців
ціну за цю війну так От чому я не хочу
коментувати насправді бачите ідуть
людину закінчуються
Зеленського тому що
всі ці хлопці вони воювали за країну всі
хто загинув вони воювали за країну не за
гроші не за владу ніколи не воювали вони
якби там не казали там росіяни ні за
Порошенка ні за Зеленського і які би там
не були в них стосунки
вони воювали за цю країну і вони за цю
країну загинули тому сьогодні
Я би хотіла говорити тільки про них про
те які ми вони були крутими про те які
ми вони були класними про те якими вони
були сміливими
про те що завдяки їхній жертви
не відбулося багато інших жертв тому
друзі
тому якось Отак я багато напевно
сьогодні буду вибачатися за якусь певну
певний такий філософічний філософський
настрій але
по інакшому не буває на прощання
буває бачите
люди люди
зустрічають ну все ми заходимо ми вже
Заходимо на Майдан
я помовчу трошки його послухаєте
[музика]
плине Качали
це брат
[музика]
лекарства
нехай мені
задаєш мир зло годину
залая смерть свого Дино
[музика]
там не знаю де погилу
саме його
краю
хто ж ми будем брати я
хто ж мені
будь ласка
[музика]
чужі
Люди виберуть ми
[музика]
це не жаль вам побуде
Хай Господи
нам компот
[музика]
гей Якби ж мені синку не жаль
якби щоб мені
синку знайшла
Ти ж на моїм серцем
вічного
[музика]
куди
[сміх]
[музика]
синів
як роса
на сонці
[музика]
Слава Україні
[оплески]
[музика]
Горить свіча Героям слава і пам'яті
сльоза додолу з неї краплями стікає
земля ридає Плачуть небеса
героїв Україна проводжає
сьогодні всі ми вся нашого неньки
Україна
проважає в останню дорогу лейтенанта до
рухова Валерія валерійовича
та старшого сержанта Барна Олега
Степановича бійців 68-ї окремої
єгерської бригади збройних сил України
та й друзі Слава Україні
[музика]
[сміх]
незалежність держави бо є земля буде
держава буде держава буде націй нема
землі нема держав нема державі не будуть
нашого народу і Нації так що
[сміх]
[музика]
і
пам'ятайте слова
головнокомандувача армії українського
Московській моржі я в українській гниди
тому що зовнішній ворог є очевидним але
страшніші прибор який вбиває своїх
захисників зі спини
[музика]
будьте об’єднані навколо України і
необхідно себе розколювати і разом ми
обов'язково переможемо Слава Україні
[музика]
Христос воскрес
дорогі друзі
побратими
громадяни
колеги депутати
прості люди
воїни
Шановний пане президенте
Петро олексійовичу
давайте для мене сьогодні напевно
найскладніший
період моєї служби
доводилося в різних обставинах бути
виносити не одного героя з поля бою але
ніколи не думав що бідні доведеться
вести рідного брата і його побратима
Валерія
так сталося
що коли стало питання
забрати брата Мене попросили хлопці
спитали з ним загинув побратим Валерій
Він загинув і чи є можливість щоб ти
його забрав в Тернополі я ж сказав кажу
ми своїх не кидаємо
і тому сьогодні вони двоє вони двоє йшли
на штурм позиції вони двоє віддали своє
життя на Донбасі воюючи проти ненависть
того російського окупанта
вони двоє ідуть додому
сьогодні хочу
подякувати усім
в першу чергу тим хто незалежно від
поглядів які які отримувався мій брат
з ним в мене були також специфічні
відносини і дискусії бо не було питання
по якому в мене дискусії з ним не було
але він точно любив Україну
він сам просився на війну і щоб Ми
зрозуміли що цей Майдан для нього це вже
не вперше в 90-му році на цьому Майдані
він був на студентській революції
гідності як студент
революції на граніті
потім Це було революція
помаранчева
далі Революція Гідності і в 14-му році
він так само пішов на фронт
захищаючи українську землю
так сталося що сьогодні ми тут разом
я щиро дякую кожному
своєму побратиму другу друзям з нашої
команди братів по зброї
європейської солідарності котрі
зініціювали саме вшанування тут наших
героїв хлопців Дякую вам за те що ви
сьогодні зробили
таку честь для
дуже скромного до життя Олега
Степановича бо він не потребував якоїсь
там колосальної уваги там він завжди
йшов
жив максимально скромним життям
тому друзі впевнений в тому що сьогодні
ми маємо об'єднати Україну
довкола спільної перемоги перемоги проти
єдиного ворога такі є в нас на сході
ми маємо мріяти про те що пам'ять про
наших героїв буде вічною
А ми переможемо
Слава Україні
шановні друзі Я також хотів би надати
слово
п'ятому президенту України Петро
Порошенко людині котру
Олег дуже любив він
знаєте Ми дискутували багато але щодо
постаті Петра Порошенка була ніколи не
було сумнівів він йшов нам бразуре він
мав свій переконання тому шановні Петра
олексійовичу прошу вас
маринована
мама
дружина сини
рідні близькі
Христос воскрес
[музика]
чи вчора пізно ввечері ми були на
Донбасі з морем
ми від імені всіх вас спробуємо все
можливе для того щоб
прискорити нашу перемогу прискорити
наступ і саме
цим
керувалися Олег
скільки разів Ми з Олегом
пройшли в цей шлях від Михайлівського до
Майдану Незалежності
Степан каже що він стояв з ним на різних
позиціях дискусій але Степан знає що я
завжди був на позиції Олег
інколи навіть ображався
яка це на диво світлолюдина
його можна було любити не любити Але не
вірити йому в його щирість було просто
неможливо
дивним чином поєднані
якості які не поєднуються
мудрість вчителя
і завтра в Тернополі
вчителі в інституті віддадуть йому свою
шану
держаність
лідера місцевого самоврядування голови
об'єднаної територіальної громади
українські справжнього народного
депутата
якого не можна було зупинити в його
любові до України
він кожен раз на своєму місці робив те
що на його думку укріпляли державності і
щодо армії
і щодо мови
і щодо віри
Я його знаю достатньо давно
ще з помаранчевої революції
Я пам'ятаю
його щирість і відданість і згадує 18
лютого коли він був поранений перед
моїми очима маріїнському парку
але це його не зупинило і він пішов в
АТО
далі лікарі йому сказали що друже ми
віддаємо статус інвалідності і все Ти
вже не маєш ходити до армії
в перший день 24 лютого
Степан долаючи всі перешкоди ламаючи як
криголав всі бюрократичні перепони
вимагав
щоб його взяли до українського війська
і він пішов 68 Бригаду
до десятої гірсько-штурмової до Степана
Ми їздили частіше
ніж до Олега
але і там
поправду кажуть що він був непростою
людиною на нього скаржилися що він
постійно вимагає бути в штурмових групах
а його пане президентом мене туди не
пускають Уявіть собі
і на Великдень
Ми з Мариною отримали від нього СМС
і дзвінок телефонний з привітанням з
Великоднем
ми подякували і сказали ну а зараз чекай
ми тебе привітаємо
Наступного дня з днем народження
коли Степану мало виповнитися 56 але він
навіки залишився
мала 56
але він навіки залишився
у Віки 55
і нам вже не відповідав
ми зразу ж степаном созвонились
Я кажу невже я не вірю і Степан кажете
саме
поки не отримую підтвердження не повірю
це були дуже важка ніч коли ми молилися
щоб це було неправда
і подивіться зараз яка величезна любов
до Олега по всій Україні
подивитися що відбувається в соціальних
мережах на телебаченні скрізь
І це дуже добре
це означає що правда
алегова правда про б'ється
але дуже класно
згадалися коли Олег цитує Петлюру
проросійських вошей
і українських гнів
оці гніди Які паплюжили
атакували
обприскували і знищували його
а сьогодні Вони намагаються
сказати що вони помилялися
сказати що вони вибачаються
так от для того щоб ці гніт
приносити вибачитись треба померти
іншого шляху не існує
от ми вийдемо з ініціативи з двома перше
для того щоб Валеру
Олега
і всіх українських героїв які були
задіяні в той бік це були штурмові дії
і обоє вони загинули
під час штурмових дій
звільняючи українську землю так щоб їх
нагородили найвищою нагородою
Оце і є шанна українського народу а не є
аж ніяк лише позиція держави а друге
Ось такі 345 приниження честі і гідності
Українського військового українського
героя
розповсюдження брехливих матеріалів
український закон каже
запроторити за грату
від трьох до п'яти років а ті хто буде
сприяти відновленню цих гніт
телемарафоні будуть співучасниками
злочину
ми Захистимо пам'ять про Олега
і доб'ємося щоби і Олег і Валера
Валера це також подивитися на світлі
блакитні очі
і хочу вам сказати що це дуже не просто
бути командиром Олега
нереально
не просто
я кажу
мене він теж називав командиром але
валяється вдалося
і сьогодні
вони обидва тут
лейтенант і старший сержант
командир і воїв і кажеться що кажуть що
в перший тиждень після Великодня двері
грає відкриті
і не треба Якщо ти причищаєшся на
сповідь ходити Господь пробачить всі
гріхи
і
Олег деклав величезних зусиль для того
щоб стала наша Українська Православна
Українська Церква
і я вірю що Господь почує наше молитви
забере його до себе
Дуже дякую
тобі Олеже Дуже дякую тобі
Валерію і на Майдані Незалежності
з чим були пов'язані
найважливіші події життя Олега і життя
України
Ми почули
На жаль величезну кількість разів коли
накачані
і На жаль сьогодні
вона присвячується Олегові присвячується
нам їх буде дуже не вистачати і це
справжні українці
вони
Одні із багатьох героїв України
які боронять сьогодні нашу рідну землю
серце зупиняється коли думаєш
скільки горя і біди прийшло на нашу
землю
але я хочу завірити вас Якщо ви нас
чуєте з небес
Ми зробимо все щоб бути гідними вашою
пам'яті
для того щоб продовжувати вашу справу
щоб виборювати
кожен сентиметр нашої рідної України
ми будемо пам'ятати І молитися за вас
щоб ви
спочивали і спокою
Слава Україні
Слава
українським Героям тричі слава
Слава нації смерть ворогам Україна понад
усе
шановні ще є бажаючі сказати декілька
слів прошу
шановна громадо
Я Андрій сивий сам командир батальйону
ОУН
я знав Олега
щодо помаранчевої революції
Олег був істинним козаком
такий колючий такий
кіт битий
кібірваний на всю голову це
він міг за собою повести людей які
поняття не мали хто він такий але от
своїм запалом оце
Я не знаю
мені дуже важко говорити Він він для
мене був рідною людиною Ми багато
набагато з ним
спарилися спорили матюкалися але завжди
коли Я
телефонував йому шахти бутівки Він
приїжджав він допомагав
передзвонював когось просив когось
нагинав і все сталося
ми з ним зустрілися випадково після
взяття карлівки це селище на водосховищі
перед військами
їхня група зайшла з невільського
Я запитав що це за відбиті такі там
взагалі там все було поміновано там
Борна каже сили негідний ти що тут робиш
Та то ж саме кажу що і ти
Потім він пішов потім він став народним
депутатом але він все одно
принайменший можливості завжди приїжджав
на передок завжди
хотів побачитися бачився з нами
потім тут коли я госпіталі лежав після
поранення в Донецькому аеропорту Він
приїжджав до мене якийсь сон привозив
півпакета каже Я дуже пити хотіла це
півпакета лежилося навіть ти зі мною
попить Ну ви розумієте Отака от людина
яка Ну я не знаю я я дуже багато З чим З
ним не погоджувався він не погоджується
зі мною ще більше але коли я звертався
Він казав ми ж літній Ну ми ж ми ж
родичі ну куди ми дінемося понімаєте ми
от духом такий от він був от козарлюга
коли отут от річка текла з вийти зверху
крові він пішов і за ним пішли хлопці і
пішла ціла толпа коли б коли йшли на
марьянский парк
до речі він тоді казав не треба туди йти
Але ви але каже Я теж піду потому що А
що я тут буду робити і і там маєвському
парку в нас розбили в цюрбані і він уже
будучи пораненим організовував
організований спуск біля
метро арсенальної організовані щоб
вернутися знову на майдан і зайняти
позиції і розпалити оце вогнище
Олешко
проси Бога за Україну ти будеш боротьбою
рядом я знаю
прощай
вибачте
шановні рідні близькі наші героїв
дійсно було сказано що символічно що на
Майдані ми прощаємося з хлопцями тому що
дійсно це таке вже сакральне місце де
всі революції проходили де виборювали
наші
Герої
і свободи і незалежність і шлях розвитку
нашої держави і не дійсно Олег був одним
з тих в перших рядах я Сотник десятої
сотні самооборони майдану тому я знаю що
таке це майданівське Братство Я знаю
чудову як після Майдану один одного ми
підтримували і ви знаєте що всі хлопці в
дівчат хто пройшов майдани в них є якісь
такі загострений
справедливості почуття І тут якраз і
напевно всім цим сказано
весь Олег тому що хотілося змін вже
сьогодні вчора а не ще чекати руками і
боротися за це але знаючи про цей
тернистий шлях
Олег не звернув з цього шляху він дальше
До кінця боровся в піхоті простим
солдатом після того що вже мав статус
народного депутата і це дійсно весь Олег
тому царство йому небесне і дійсно Я
впевнений що він буде поряд біля Бога
Валеру дійсно як було сказано що
командир в Олега це вже напевно багато
що сказано що така людина була
у легкому підпорядковувалася тобто міг
знайти слова щоб вгамувати деколи
забагато тих такого настирливого Олега
тому
приміщення співчуття і він за Олега і за
Валеру ви знаєте я в 14-му році ми
звільняли Славянск батальйону і генерала
Кульчицького і
з фамілією дорого ми пересікалися це
була інша людина але Повірте не менш
таким Патріот не не менш
воїн тому
фамілія дорогу то кажу знають і будуть
дійсно як Петро Олексійович сказав
будуть знати всі ми докладемо цього
зусилля Слава Україні
Слава Ісусу Христу
торга родина
дорогі матері дорогі дружини дорогі діти
дорогі друзі дорогі майданівці збройні
сили України Я хочу цей уклін
як символ вдячності
командиру
В якому всього 31 рік
Валерію і своєму побратиму
коменданту старшому сержанту
Олегові яким було в мене розмова в
березні коли він там мене з днем
народження
а вдень його народження ми зібралися
як воїни
Валерій і Олег
Воїни світла
воїни патріоти
воїни гідності
воїни які після смерті
залишили пам'ять вічності
пам'ять непоборності пам'ять гідності і
пам'ять християнської молитви молитви за
Україну
молитви за
майбутнє України
і командири Комендант
поєднали
У вічність роздуми нашу відповідальність
і все буде Україна слава Україні слава
Героям Герої не вмирають
Христос воскрес
дуже боляче знайомитись з валерієм в
таких обставинах це покоління дійсно
наших дітей і ми ніколи не позитивно
ворогом за те що вони вбивають тих хто
мав би будувати Україну не буде
прощенням ми мали честь бути в одній
команді з барнами і з Олегом і з
степаном і десь два тижні тому ми з
Машею З цього пили каву
Десь там під краматорском на заправці і
звичайно вперше завжди було питання Як
там Олег Стьопа дуже сварив Олега каже
нам абсолютно безбашений їде вона
якісь гарячіші історії ну такі моти був
весь Олег весь Олег таким ви знаєте Я
сьогодні і ми всі От коли дізнались цю
страшну історію ми згадуємо Олега дуже
живого цю його таку Тернопільського
Вірку він щоранку підходив там Іринко
привіт якось так це договорив з такою
теплотою Він дуже любив свою родину він
скільки розповідав про свою дружину про
своїх хлопців про своїх синів і це
велике щастя що Олег був щасливою
людиною в нього чудові батьки у нього
брат брат Велике щастя в нього Прекрасна
родина і ми від цього серця хочемо
побажати вам сили мужності це пережити
мамі Валерія я не знаю навіть що
говорити ми бажаємо всім
безумовно була велика мрія про перемогу
головна мрія в нього була мрія Україна в
її сената і в нього були земні от я весь
час згадую про одну його земну мрію яку
він теж підходив ринку Я хочу поїхати
відрядження в Америку я хочу побувати в
Америці Оскільки в цьому було такого
знаєте людського і так далі чому взяли
зараз всі ці дні про це згадує думаю
Боже Америка скільки ще маєте ви наше
дорогі партнери допомогти нам для того
щоб у нас були більше зброї у нас було
більше техніки в нас було все те що
допоможе оцим відчайдухам да
перемогти тому що головна мета - це
перемога і я просто хочу від нашої
команди вклонитися родинам за Валерія за
Олега і сказати що ми будемо робити все
що в наших силах для того щоб
ці важливі дуже високі мрії і їх
жертовність щоб вони реалізувалися
олегами дуже любимо Ми маємо велику
честь сьогодні познайомитись з валерієм
ми Повірте що ми теж його не
років
так він за Україну голову яка країна що
сказав Слава Україні
і Олега і Валерія я не знала ні Валерій
не Олег але я хочу вам подякувати за
ваше синів і за те що вони захищають мою
донеччину мій Бахмут за те що вони
віддають найцінніше своє життя
як ми і співаємо Душу тіло ми положимо
за нашу свободу Я не знаю тисяч тих хто
віддав життя але їм буду до кінця життя
вдячна за те що я живу
немає мого бахмута але є пам'ять і Наша
задача зберегти цю пам'ять ніколи ніколи
не забувати і робити все в своїх
містечках
для того щоб пам'ятали
щоб кожне наступне покоління пам'ятали
якою ціною ми здобуваємось нашу свободу
я вам Щиро щиро дякую вклоняємось Дякую
Слава Україні
в бою Я був з ними ми були разом
ми не повезло я Ну тільки обійшовся
ми були штурмовики в штурмовиках тільки
найкраще
тому я хочу сказати що вони не краще
задача яка була в нас поставлена ми не
просто виконали зробили більше даже
більше чим ми мали зробити Я хочу
звернутись до батьків до дітей що ви
можете гордіти своїм синами своїм
батьком вони не просто так полягли
Валерій це він нас просто майстер він
нас найкраще Він завжди був перший і нас
все в червні і підготовляв завжди
Степанович Степанович це характер
Степанович теж Ми йому говорили навіть я
до нього звертався і говорив Степанович
ви не підете не потягнете те що
Степан завжди доброволець там де всі і
завжди він там ми дуже гордимося 68-ї
бригаді дуже низькі поклін вам хлопці
Слава Україні Героям слава
Україні
шановні товариство
дорога Україну
дорогі друзі близькі
знайомі родину
всі хто сьогодні
разом з нами
[музика]
тут
разом з нами
разом з нами у волонтерці
разом з нами на кожному кроці якого
потребує сьогодні Україна
Дякую вам всім і кожного
за те
що ви були
з моїм чоловіком
з татом моїх синів
сином його батьків
з братом
Степана
одні його життя
[музика]
підтримували його
направляли
колись сварили
колись
пишалися
колись погоджувалися А колись ні бо Олег
був не простою людиною Я завжди йому
казала що Олег я з тобою як на вулкані
Я не знаю коли іде в стрілить
але знаю що в стріли точно
і знаю що стрілить в правильне місце
він був
боголюбивим
його Бог не раз рятував з великих
передрях і коли нам сказали що
втратився зв'язок
то я навіть не хвилина не сумнівалася в
тому що він видряпається
бо він дуже міцно тримався
за ту землю
за ту країну
як вони інші любив
ми всі знали і Він завжди говорив
що я люблю вас всіх
але Україна найбільша
і це були не просто слова
це були вчинки
Він був людиною дії
людиною слова
яка не оглядалася на те що скажуть про
нього інші
він мав свою думку
і цю думку було дуже тяжко переперти
але
певно на таких людях
і тримається наша земля
вони є стержнями вони є каменями
вони є глибоко
які
жоден москаль не посуди
тільки ніхто Ніякий
хат не зможе переламати
Дякую всім
хто у часі його Борнів
був разом з ним плід чи обліч
бо військове Братство То є дуже сильне
Братство коли ти
не думаєш про себе а захищаєш того хто
поряд
дзвінках коли
чоловік дзвонив додому Він дуже
стиклотою
розповідав про своїх хлопців
про те як вони
і ніколи не говорив що там тяжко
він не був нетиком він не плакався на
Тім тягості військової служби тому що
був там де було не з медом
і йшов у бій і ми знали що він іде у бій
бо він знав що він має вдома добрий ти
який молиться
який
бореться
який всіляко шукає допомоги
шукає побратимів шукає товариство яке
задонатить тому що десь там треба десь
щось треба я дякую
Величезне дякую усім волонтерам справі
громад Петро олексійовичу за те що
наших воїнів
не лишають сам на сам
голими руками із ворогом
ми маємо в Україні дуже
сильного ворога який століттями
точив зброю
бо хотів нас знищити
а не вийде
не вийде бо Олег завжди казав
Навіть не сумнівайся
перемога Буде за нами
сьогодні зі струю
в небесне воїнство
ідуть
молодий зовсім юний воїн
якому ще жити і жити
якому будувати плани
і требувати бабу яка лишається сама
Сьогодні іде чоловік який прожив життя і
Біг цим життям він спішив жити
але він не спішив вмерти у нього було
стільки планів
дай Бог Кожен був
від його влади
візьміть його влади собі
Нехай у кожного буде план на щодень на
кожну мить
на молитву на працю на відбудову і на
віру
бо тільки разом ми зможемо ці плани
втілити в життя і побудувати таку
Україну за яку загинули хлопці
за яку гинуть
Я не хочу щоб більше гинули я бачу
сьогодні багато військових хлопців
Живіть
живіт заради тих хто сьогодні загинув
боріться так щоби ви вийшли з поля бою
вийшли переможцями Бо нам треба будувати
Україну нас дуже багато роботи
і хай та Україну буде такою
про яку мріяв яку
бажав
яку малював
в тому числі і в своїх образах і в своїх
картинах Олег
Він ніколи не мріяв бути воїном
з нього був дуже добрий вчитель так
вимогливий строгий
вчитель який хотів
щоб
виросла мудра
здорова думаюча
і Перспективна нація
нація переможців і нація будівничих
двоє пішло
Хай не є їхнє місце стане четверо
Хай їхні ряди поповнять ті
хто не буде дивитися ні на які
перестороги Олег говорив якщо я людина з
інвалідністю можу
то можуть всі
сьогодні багато поранених Візьміть
приклад з нього
як людина якій не давали жодного шансу
на життя і то не один раз
міг сам себе підняти на ноги
міг не змиритися з того
що він
маючи чотири
шурупи в тазі
він іде в армію у нього вибити плече він
бере в томат У нього вибита нога і він
взуває берці у нього контузія після
Майдану і він світлим розумом приймає
рішення
боріться
Не бійтеся А вийтися ми все переможемо
ми побудуємо Україну таку за яку
сьогодні
загинули за яку борються і за яку кожен
має жити
жити на славу Україні
Слава Україні
дякую вам
я хочу від вас також
своєї родини Родини наших
нашої родини Барні
подякувати вам усім друзі що ви тут з
нами
подякувати
п'ятому президенту України Петро
Олексійовича Порошенка Марині
Анатоліївні нашій команді
європейської солідарності
друзі побратимів незалежно від партійної
приналежності
за те щоб проводжаєте наших героїв
Дякую керівництво Верховної Ради
по собі голови Верховної Ради України і
тернополянин і напевно також не мало чув
про Олега
Руслану стефанчику коли прийшов сюди
думаю
що приклад Олега
і Валерія це буде для нас прикладом
боротьби
вони йшли на пролом
мало хто вірив в результативність цієї
операції котру робили хлопці
біля населеного пункту Павлівка на
Донбасі
але вони це зробили
зробили ціною свого життя молодий
люблять
Україну
навіть я так
мого брата Що Своя історія
так історія військова ми говорили його
проривицю революціонера
він був гранатометником кулеметником
артилеристом
а сьогодні я думаю який він собі місце
зайшов
думаю гарантовано він поповнив
Легіон воїнів
тронщиків разом з валерієм вони будуть
надійно на голови окупантів російських
спрямовувати
гранати
коректувати Вогонь і давати можливість
перемагати і звільняти українську землю
перше дякую
братові
за те що було в музиці
скажіть
може бути
два брати нас три брати
з різними поглядами на життя але Ми
любили і любимо
свою землю
тому друзі Всім дякую за те що ви є
і
впевнений що перемога буде за Україною
Слава Україні
що хочу сказати
тато для мене був другом він для мене
був вчителем чи в мене фізику в мене
було в нього 12 не просто тому що я його
син а тому що він він був педагогом від
Бога
з його допомогою я вигравав в обласній
олімпіади з фізики це показник що він
був професіоналом своєї справи правду
сказали що він ніколи не хотів бути
військовим Він був педагогом він був
державником він не був політиком Він не
думав про власну вигоду
для нього гроші це були звичайні яких
він не старався назбирати все що він
хотів він хотів щоб люди жили краще люди
трималися Купи і знали хто їх ворог
знали що ворог прийде зі сторони Росії
не дуже важко зараз бачити тата тут
ще на Великдень він в мене вітав
І він казав що все буде добре
Він казав одружується робіть сім'ю я
дуже хочу онуків
Ми знали що він буде дуже гарним дідусем
він віддавши добру третину свого життя
віддав за справу яку він вірив
він віддав її за Україну
Я пам'ятаю якось зайшов до нього в
Комітет Верховної Ради в кабінет
і в кабінеті
в нього були чотири репортрети
портрети людей в яких він вірив
Це був портрет його президента Петра
Олексійовича в якого він вірив
Це був портрет наших героїв Степана
Бандери і Романа Шухевича людей чи
приклад він був для нього неймовірно
важливим
і ще в нього портрет був
поета
який був йому напевно найближче до серця
це був Іван Франко
коли прийдете додому Прочитайте собі
вірш його
про вічного революціонера
тато не любив коли йому
представляли якісь епітети але Вічний
революціонер це про мого батька
я дякую йому за той вплив на моє життя
який він зробив
його вклад був найбільшим і його справа
буде жити в нас його дітям
батько був такою людиною
А ну ми села знаєте такою людиною що він
навіть курка не обідить
але
за Україну Він був готовий вбивати і він
помер за неї
хочу взяти всім
чиї батьки
чистими чи рідні воюють
подзвонить до них і скажіть зараз як
вони пишаєтесь
Можливо
ми це вже більше ніколи не скажете
Вічна слава і вічна пам'ять творцям за
волю України слава Україні
героям слава
смерть ворогам
найгіркіше проводжати сьогодні
своїх синів рідних
близьких тим що
росте і разом були сьогодні
Як голова Київського товариства
Лемківщина і представляє Тернопільське
землянство в місті Києві
уповноважені Просили мене всі люди і
лемки і тернополяничі на Тернопільщині
виставити
найсердечніші співчуття рідним і всім
друзям і всій Україні
але чому Олег такий нестримний був Чому
він був такий шалений як кажуть адже
його дідуся депортували з великої
родиною з Польщі 500 тисяч українців
було депортовано Україну
чи на навчання і підлящ і раз втративши
рідну землю ревно цінує оберігає і
захищає свою нову батьківщину Україну
Олег народився вже на Тернопільщині не
там але батьки дідусі бабусі можете
розказували на певний йому маленькій
дитині як гірко було покидати рідну
землю як важко її було втрачати і він як
ніхто ішов як багато легенькі багато
тернополяни всі українці пішли захищати
своє рідну землю
Олегу сьогодні у два воїни перед нами
гірко прощатись всім нам навіть які не
такі близькі як рідні але їм Олегу
найбільше пасує слова Великого
лемківського поета і віє вітер відстоїть
крилатий вільний і нестримний і вчись
Свободи туги вчить за чимсь незнаним і
нестримним такий був вільний і і Олег і
тому цей гірський характер Чому брати
рідний Степан каже що він був такий що
нестримний важко було з ним вести
дискусію Тому що йому передався до
гірський ті гори які виховали його
предків і він як кажуть
захистив нас дуже гірко нам це знати і
ми всі схвильовані всіленькі Києва і не
тільки Києва всі світу доля нас
розкидано наші тернополяни наші
Тернопільські земля 10 місяців Києві
сьогодні дуже сумують шанують і просили
низкоплений і писаріним і Спасибі
хлопцям А ми Закликаємо всіх хто живі
хто може ходити ногами ще зробити все
для перемоги в тилу не тільки чекати що
ж там коли закінчиться війна Хто де може
як може прислужитися перемозі
робити все що можливо і неможливо щоб
швидше і цю перемогу щоб хлопцям на
небесах не було за нас соромно низькі
об'ємим хлопці
хто бажає підходьте при цьому щось добре
хороше це буде знак прощання прошу хто
вважає підходьте прощатись
[музика]
сам не знаю де
погилу
саме
любов неповний
[музика]
тний помилуй
я
пагін моя
краю
тож ми будем брати я
ву хто
твій доля
[музика]
брати я
буду вернуть ми
[музика]
Чуєш ти нажати вам кому
буде
сильне
бажання нам
[музика]
Господи
Якби ж ти мені синку на
жаль якби жа
лей
міста
[музика]
моє серце
бо ти синій
пливе Качан бо ти синів
[музика]
Плине кача по Тисині
Лине кача буде синів
[музика]
мав Кош моя неба й мені
мамка ж моя
[музика]
сам не знаю де тобі слава
люди Поки
нув
Гей погинув я в чужим краю
[музика]
Алилуя що їм краю
тож ми будем брати я
ру хто ж
вибрати яму
[музика]
вернутими чу
Ти ж на моїм серцю лежала
не жаль
[музика]
нікому не качав поки
сина кача
[музика]
Амінь
ди
[музика]